you went to the Saturday Night Live uh
reunion right there yeah I was there did
you have a good time or were you
miserable no no I've had a good time
because it was kind of like speaking of
miserable like when I was there
sometimes I feel like you know I
definitely had like an attitude a lot of
times in the course of my life when I
look back you know and I'm amazed about
your attitude yeah I mean your attitude
started at a very young age you
described when you were very young in
your new book you described someone
would want to meet with you about a
movie and you would be such a cocky
[__] and I love this you sat down
they go to you what do you think of the
script now of course you're supposed to
say the script's great I want to be in
it you go script [__] me and my friends
are rewrite it yeah who does that
because I was very arrogant about
comedians yeah I was like I just I lived
in this little world of Comedy so I was
like we know everybody else doesn't know
anything we know what hack is well I
mean I was right if you watch most
movies that [__] they are shitty right
most movies and TV shows are [__] right
I'm not wrong I was just wrong in the
sense that it's none of my business
right to to tell people what to do think
when you were at Saturday Night Live you
still had that cocky attitude no here's
what happens I showed up and Saturday
Night Live you know Fred Wolf was the
one that said Lauren you got to see this
guy Lauren saw me I bomb so but I mean
one of the great bombs even for me
according to David Spade if you bomb
that's how you get on Saturday Night
Live they don't like a guy who's too uh
good well yeah we don't like you don't
like people that just a crowd-pleaser
type thing it's just overly accessible
you know what I mean right Lauren likes
a little attitude you know what I mean
Edge he goes oh yeah so he's like but
he's I bombed so bad he was even like he
even told me he goes well you saved
yourself from being in the on the air
with that one you're just a writer now
you know so yeah he looks impossible and
then um but then he hired me and then I
was there for a while and I started
getting on the show and Lauren love me I
mean Lauren treated me like lawn treated
me great there right really great I mean
I'm actually surprised Lauren hired you
because you were on remote control yes
and usually he's looking for a complete
unknown and remote control did give you
a degree of Fame but a high degree of
Fame from him give me a high degree yeah
I'm surprised he wasn't like kind of hey
man you know you were on MTV yeah he's
the best boss about him he goes he used
to say this is not MTV a lot he would
say that a lot to me and so when you
went to the 40th anniversary do you find
you're like kind of an outsider in a way
or yeah I mean I made my I mean I'm not
an outsider but I made myself an outside
like I just kind of
I just like I know I just have a weird
like I was very uh
in the end
my last couple years I was just very
selfish like it was all about me here's
what happened first of all I felt weird
like being uh like loins like being like
the the favorite like I felt
uncomfortable and I shunned that so I
walk away from that in other words it's
uncomfortable being teacher's pet so
right in a way you wanna you almost want
to be like the rest of the crew and not
be singled out because this teacher's
pet has pressure on them and then and
you don't want to be that even though
you know it's a good thing but in life
but you still have that old thing from
when you're a kid and then the norm when
Norm then I took over for norm and that
was when I I feel like I even sabotaged
it because I felt so guilty even I had
nothing to do with Norm leaving right
but it was still wow I'm taking I'm
taking Norm's thing after they fire him
for this whole thing normal Norm was an
amazing uh Anchorman uh for the news he
he was funny as hell and what was so
weird was he was dismissed as not being
funny it was a shameful kind of
dismissal for a guy who's so talented
yes and then poor you you're taking over
for him and you have nothing to do with
it you didn't sabotage his job no I
didn't but I hung out with him the whole
time right he was one of your best
friends he was my best friend there we
hung out all the time did you call him
and say I know you just got fired I feel
horrible about this but they've asked me
to be the Anchorman or were you just I
don't remember how it went down but it
was ugly Not only was it weird I mean he
was a real gentleman I'll be honest with
you he was a total like uh gentleman
like he made it but it but it was just
so it was pathetic you know but anyway
it made me weird in that spot the whole
time I was there it was just like a it
was like a curse in other words like
it's like he couldn't own it and enjoy
it I couldn't own it and enjoy him isn't
that terrible when you look back on it
now you said do you say to yourself I
should have just owned it and enjoyed it
I should have had you know why did I
make it so horrible yeah or I should
have just left I should have just left
after that after a few shows I should
have said I can't do this it's whatever
the energy was that I was bringing but
yeah no exactly I couldn't enjoy it so I
loved I loved my first two and a half
years I've loved it more than anything
you know what I mean yeah it was fun and
this and doing the update thing was just
ugly it ruined it for you it almost made
you ruin it I still like when I'm going
back to the 40th I was so happy to be
back there and all the good memories
flooded back but the good memories of
the first two and a half years
foreign